guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast
and one reason i'm doing this one this
is because for many years due to variety
of reasons
i hesitated to recite quran because i
had internal intentions because
[Music]
bismillah
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you
your progress with your soul yes that's
correct not only does it encourage you
to read it tells you how many verses
you've read how many pages you read how
long you've been on it and best of all
the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters in
defense
uh ramadan mubarak to all of you guys
and may allah accept our fast
and uh enter us into jannah amongst
those who have fasted for his sake
in this video i'm going to be reciting
surah al-fatiha inshallah and i'm going
to be talking about one specific verse
in there
which i found very profound and i'm
going to tell you guys why i'll be
reciting and i'm going to be doing a
couple more videos of
recitations as well inshallah and i'm
going to nominate three people
to do the same in the mind for ramadan
because it's the month of the quran
[Music]
bismillah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now i love swarafati and that restation
was i was imitating ali jabbar may i
love mercy on him i'll put a link into
one of his videos absolutely beautiful
sword
specifically um now one of the verses
one specific verse in surah that i love
and this what
this is one of the reasons that i would
say i've come to islam
you alone we worship and you alone we
ask for help
brothers and sisters these statements
are so profound this is the mother of
the book
surah is the mother of the quran and
brothers and sisters subhanallah
this statement distinguishes islam from
all religions around the world when
people come and say to me
oh you know all religions go through the
same roots all this kind of none of them
i don't think you understand islam is
the only religion
this specific statement is what makes
islam unique
you alone we worship and you alone we
ask for help
the pinnacle of tahit and differentiates
even muslims who
practice forms of shirk by going to the
graves and asking the dead
yeah um and there's i don't want to get
into the whole nitty-gritty of that
there's many videos done by mufti munir
sheikh thai white has a brilliant video
which i'm going to put which he breaks
down
one specific individual who um claims
that it's
the act going and asking people that
that is haram not shirk
but watch that video it's very
beneficial but brothers and sisters in a
nutshell
this here is what makes us different
because
this here this statement when it comes
to all other religions they always have
some kind of
other means be it for example going
through jesus
or hindus having multiple gods or the
quraysh themselves
who would worship alot and they would
worship these people and they would say
look and they affirmed in the quran
allah says that they would
if allah if he was to ask him who
created heavens in the earth they'll say
allah
they affirm allah he is the lord
but they committed [ __ ] in this only
here by his in his worship they would
say
we go to god through these people and
that's what the christians do that's
what the hindus do that's what other
people do
they go through via other means so that
is the reason why
this is my favorite uh verse
in surah fatiha inshallah
and this is what makes islam the pure
monotheistic
and an adultered version of tawheed
monotheism inshallah i want to nominate
musa
zeeshan and muhammad hijab to inshallah
do the same by reciting
a specific verse in the quran or it can
be a specific chapter
and talking about what is it one verse
that you like in that specific chapter
so please send this to them to musa
to muhammad hijab anti-zi sean it's the
month of quran
let's recite the quran inshallah if you
would like me to do more recite in
different parts
verses of the quran and different places
please let me know inshallah and i can
carry on doing it inshallah
and one reason i'm doing this wrong this
is because for many years
due to variety of reasons um i hesitated
to recite quran
in uh be public in the context in videos
etc
uh because i had internal intentions
because obviously i was always
well i was always like kind of told that
you know you can't read the quran and
all this kind of stuff people used to
say stuff
and i didn't want to prove them wrong
for my sake i didn't want to go there
like oh no i can't recite the quran i've
memorized this or
i know how to read or this that i didn't
want to do that because then it would
have been
doing it just to prove them wrong i
wanted to do it for the sake of allah
and i believe after variety of years
i've come to the point where i believe
now this is
genuinely for the sake of allah and that
is the reason i'm doing this inshallah
i hope this is a benefit to you guys may
allah bless every single one of you guys
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh